they say the jewish proverbs says
there's three things every man should do
write a book plant a tree have a son
why because they all outlive you we as
men want to live thousands of years
the only way you're going to live
thousands of years is by the value you
bring to the world that's documented
is by giving back to and i know the tree
is what they're saying with tree not
even tree today because a tree is being
cut down and turning to paper it's a
business model not right
but it's family it's blood
and when you see your kid and you
find somebody to build a family with
that's a good partner
meshes with you good personality you sit
there and say okay great this looks good
we can actually pull this off then
there's value for it
[Music]
and so one of one of the things is
there's a a lot of conversations about
you know the behaviors of very
successful men
and um you know and and i always said
there's there's levels to the game you
know there's there's the guys that
you know the hundred thousands there's a
million there's a 10 million you know
pass at the top of the level you know i
mean pat is a guy who was an extremely
successful man a lot of people will show
things on social media
but patrick hands down successful man
that you cannot deny so one of the
questions
that people always ask is what is the
incentive of a very successful
especially financially successful man
to settle down and become and get
married so i'm very curious about from
your personal perspective as a man who
was being successful
who had a onward trajectory who was
doing so well what
made you decide to get married the risk
is very high by the way to get married
you know for for me when i was 28 i had
made a decision i'm never going to get
married
oh wow i'm staying single and my
assistant very good friend of mine at
that time sandra patty
said why don't you go read this book 101
questions to ask before you get engaged
by norman wright so i read the book
when i read the book i'm like huh
interesting i was talking to four girls
at the time i said why don't you guys
read this book as well and see how you
feel about it
so they did i'm like i could never be
with you you and i would never work
out would never work out but i asked the
one question
why get married there's way too much
risk to it
so i sat there and said well you have
somebody to come home to every night
you can still have somebody to come up
if you're single matter of fact you can
have options
yeah if you you know what i mean when
you have the money you can do whatever
you want to do with that
yeah but uh tax benefits i don't care
about that i can move to another state
and get better tax benefits
it's it's somebody that you're you know
it's somebody that can help you it's
somebody that can do this
not not there yet and then it goes to
okay look you can make all the money in
the world
then what like what leaves you a book
yeah they say the jewish proverb says
there's three things every man should do
write a book plant a tree have a son
why because they all outlive you we as
men want to live thousands of years
the only way you're going to live
thousands of years is by the value you
bring to the world that's documented
is by giving back to and i know the tree
is what they're saying with tree not
even tree today because a tree is being
cut down and turning into paper it's a
business model not right
but it's family it's blood
and when you see your kid and you
find somebody to build a family with
that's a good partner
meshes with you good personality you sit
there and say okay great this looks good
we can actually pull this off then
there's value for it but i'm going to
tell you something here right now basic
rules about getting married today
wouldn't get me if i'm a man i'm not
getting married before 30. at
all i would not even think about getting
married pre-dirty a lot of people argue
with me
you know what you're talking about i got
married at 22 years old and i'm happily
married i'm 62.
22 62 that was 40 years ago that means
the 80s
yeah you didn't have social media you
didn't have snapchat you didn't have
tinder you don't have accessibility to
what's out there today
accessibility to sex today is so easy
the ability to be tempted today and
screw up is so easy the ability to screw
up and make a royally publicly
humiliating mistake today
is very high and a no man walk on water
okay and no man walks on water everybody
sees oh my gosh
she's beautiful but i'm american there's
nobody that's perfect to say oh i don't
have to worry about the mistakes i'm
gonna make
the risk is high today the reward
is not as high as it used to be because
at least back in the days you know back
in the days
say you and your wife count to a fight
20 years ago you got a 30 minute drive
okay and at the office you talked to her
well i want to come home and talk to you
tonight
you got 30 minutes to calm down by the
time you come home today if you get into
a fight
instantly that's second what you want to
say you say so you offend you fan you
offend your fans scar scar
scar scar it's just like dude i'm so
done with this marriage so
today we have too much of the
opportunity to react
instantly there's too much instant
reaction
and hey you don't know what you're
talking about that fight is too instant
so those are all scars that you're
leaving on each other right
and eventually after all the scars you
get it's like i just i just have no
desire to do anything with you in bed
anymore i really don't i'm good i'm just
you're facing this way
she's facing that way so it has to be
built on the right values and principles
it has to be somebody that you date for
some time and you see all the dark side
of them and yourself to see if you can
do this or not
preferably a referral that's coming
through somebody instead of cold
i knew my wife five and a half years
before we got married she knew my flaws
i knew her flaws oh yeah she dated other
guys i did it other girls and
eventually we said let's see what could
happen here and we build a family
together
you have to create certain criterias uh
before you and when you get married
watch the fights watch the arguments
watch how people argue i remember one
time my wife
we were dating and
she is about to lose uh financially she
was in the best of place at that time
certain you know challenges took place
she was in a mortgage real estate
business
in one month she cause we've been
together for three months she says
you know this month i don't know how i'm
going to pay my rent
i'm like okay let's see where this goes
yeah i don't know i'm going to pay my
rent like really yeah
what are you thinking you're going to do
i don't know what do you think i should
do
i said well number one i would go return
your bmw that you have that's 850
car payment wipe convertible i'd go
return that and say can't pay the
payment anymore
what else would you do number two i'd go
back and i would get a nissan centra 200
a month that saves you 600 bucks a month
okay what else would you do
i'd go back and i know you're doing
insurance and real estate right now i'd
go back and get your old job where you
worked
to give you a good shift where they can
pay you 40 000 that at least covers your
uh
what do you call it expenses what else
would you do boom boom i said what i
said
and she says okay so what do you mean
let's go return the car i see you sure
that day yeah we drove to bmw she
returned her car then we dropped up to
centra she got the center then she went
back to her job and she got a job
and she said i said never once did she
say can you lend me 1250 bucks not one
time
so to me that was like okay because my
biggest concern was oh i have money so
you're kind of trying to
yeah i never did that and i said she has
no clue she just passed an incredible
test
for us right so i it's it's very risky
and there is no hundred percent
everything about marriage today's odds
and sometimes you can have a fight that
no matter what you know kansas city
chiefs are supposed to win the super
bowl
and brady could still win so you can
still do all of it right
and the odds are in your favor for this
marriage to work it could still fail
yeah
no that that that that is a conversation
that we're always having and i think to
me
similar to you i think the advantage of
a man's ability to raise his son is so
important
in today especially as the world gets
more and more crazier i just think
you know that's one of the incentive
centers for me is that like similar to
how my father
was able to be in my life and i know you
shared a story last time on the podcast
how
having that one week with your dad one
day a week with your dad
really shaped your life and i always
said that i grew up very rich
and people like oh my gosh you know
you're spoiled how much cards you're
like no no we
my parents were they were immigrants we
had no money but my dad gave me so much
love and time and that's and that was
the richness that i grew up with so
yeah for me the the beauty and value is
in that for marriage
and so you made a point about criteria
for selecting a wife so if your son
was 32 years old you know he established
himself financially you you see he's
doing well he and he's trying to settle
down
what would would be three criteria that
you give him for a wife that comes off
the top of your mind
yeah so first of all you have to be
physically attracted so i'm that's not
even one of the three but you do have to
be physically attracted
so the whole idea about well it doesn't
matter oh no it it
matters okay it matters and by the way
my wife and i until today we talk and we
say hey
you know we have to stay in shape for
each other we have to be attractive to
each other you know we have to want to
have sex with each other because
that is a very important part of
marriage so it's not like
280 pounds but you said through thick
and thin yeah it's a little too much
thick right now and i'd like something
right you know but
you know so so that is a part and
sometimes men let themselves go and you
see
you know they got a big pouch well you
know but you're my wife that's not how
things work you know you have to so
but let's set that part aside let's set
that part aside um
for me number one would be values and
principles and i'll explain to you from
my parents standpoint my parents might
both my parents are christians right but
why do you get a divorce here's why my
mom was a communist
my dad was an imperialist my mother
believed rich people were bad people
my dad thought poor people were lazy
look how big of a conflict that is yeah
so my dad's trying to become rich but
that's who my
mom hates how can your husband become
exactly what you hate the more my dad's
aspiring to become rich
the more you despise rich people why
would he become rich you don't like rich
people
i don't know if that made sense or not
yeah so it's kind of like dude i'm
trying to really give you the life but
she despises
rich people so values and principles to
me
politics is almost more important than
religion
people say why would you say that that's
so weird okay so if a christian marries
a catholic yeah they're both christians
little bit different for christian
marries a
you know a jew okay one's a christian
one's a jew but it's very different
patrick i get it
but ten commandments ten commandments
okay
same values and principles in that area
but
economically if you believe
certain economy is going to be one way
and she believes in a different way
if you believe politically once that and
she will you're causing too many fights
and you're causing way too many things
for kids to also have more fights with
so
philosophically you got to be on the
same page you know the
the magic the excitement's got to be
there when you're around each other it's
not going to be like that forever
because
you know when you have kids you can't
have sex for three months and it's gonna
be a lot of things that's gonna hurt the
magic at times but
there's gotta be that twinkle where
you're like man i can't wait to see i
can't wait to go have that dinner with
her right
uh and then you know ask a lot of
questions up front man i asked
so let me ask you this yeah what are we
going to do one day at this time what
would you do one time i asked my wife i
said
let me ask you if we get into a big
fight okay terrible fight i'm talking
horrible fight we're together for nine
months when i ask this question
i said who would you call she said i
would call this person that person this
person this person this person i said
okay
so i got a paper and pennant tell me
about this person are they married
no she's divorced okay tell me about
this person
tell me about that person i said i said
yeah i'm not ready to get married
she's why not i said because everybody
you call
is going to defend you and they need to
defend me
but everyone's going to defend you she
says what do you mean who are you going
to call
if we get into a fight i said let me
tell you who i said dudley
my dad and i went through a list of the
names that i would call
i said you know what every one of these
guys would defend who you
they would all say i messed up to come
and apologize to you i said you see the
challenge is
if i have way too many divorced friends
divorce friends like to recruit
people to the divorce community wow
married people like to recruit people
to the married community single people
like to recruit people to what
single community we're all recruiters by
the way so so
when you get married it's very important
that most of the people you're around is
also what
like you yeah or else you're going to be
tempted so i made the list she made the
list so you guys got to have the
conversation we asked and say if
something happens who are we going to
call
and then i'm telling you 90 of the
questions you're asking using 101
questions to ask before you get engaged
baggage what do you bring to the table
you know what what things do i have to
worry about
x's are you comfortable with a kid i
guess the last one i would add with you
would be the following
create a list of your three
non-negotiables which means
look no matter what we have to be both
same faith hypothetically no matter what
you can't have any kids
no matter what you can't be married
before or no matter what you can't have
this
nomad create your three no matter what
and don't create a 20 no matter what
only three no matter what so you got to
think about all the no matter what's and
then
narrow it down to what three once you
have your three
never compromise the three many people
do
just because the sex is good yeah or
just because she's too pretty
or just because he's way handsome or
just because you know
you cannot compromise your
non-negotiable when i'm running a
company a guy came up and he says hey
pat let's do a deal on the side i'm
going to pay you a million dollars here
and this is when i was smaller someone
pay a million dollars no one's going to
know let's do a side contract
i see you know what's crazy says what's
i said you have no idea how much i need
that meal
he says i said you have no idea how much
i need that million right now i'm
telling you i need that million right
now because i'm bleeding
i said but you know if one of my guys
finds out who's loyal to me that i did a
side deal with them with you even though
i've never known you before we just
started like six months ago
i said i lose trust with all i said i
can't do that it's part of my
non-negotiable as i can do it so i
appreciate the offer
but i cannot take you on that he was
blown away yeah because everybody else
said
because one of my non-negotiable was win
your existing
loyal people over and never disrespect
them
always protect them once you do that and
you're going into a marriage
you know you're hopefully the odds will
be on your side but still it's very
important to know
there is no perfect perfection when it
comes down to that
yeah if you wait for that part you'll
never if you actually do want to get
married
there is no perfection yeah there is
risk yeah
there is concern your heart could be
broken
things could go wrong but you're just
hoping the odds
are on your side